How the heck does that work?!
Hey Crazies.
If you’ve ever looked through polarized
sunglasses, you might have noticed some weird stuff
Like a difficulty seeing your phone screen.
I’m sure your reaction was a lot like Question
Clone’s.
What the Fraunhofer?!?!
I’ve got an answer for you and, as usual,
there will be lots of details.
Because asylum crazies think deep!
The lenses in polarized sunglasses are coated
in a material called a polarizer because it
polarizes light.
Scientists tend to name things more descriptively
than creatively.
Anyway, this leaves us with a logical place
to start:
What does it mean to polarize light?
To answer that, we need to review a little.
Light is often shown to be an electromagnetic
wave like this.
Since the electric part has more influence
over things, we tend to focus more attention
on that.
We call that direction the wave’s polarization.
What do you mean it has influence over things?
What things?
Atoms.
Well, parts of atoms.
Here’s the train of thought:
Atoms are made of charges.
Charges respond to electric fields.
Light has an electric field.
Therefore, by the transitive property, atoms
respond to light.
We’ve been talking a lot lately about electrons
absorbing light and jumping to higher energy
levels.
In a solid, that extra energy is not
likely to be re-emitted as light.
It’s far more likely to be transferred to
nearby atoms making them jiggle faster,
warming up the solid instead.
Polarizers are more like glass.
They transmit visible light.
They don’t hold onto it.
Their atoms don’t have the right energy
levels for that.
However, by the argument we just made, the
atoms should still respond to the
light somehow.
Let’s take a closer look at this glass.
SUPER ZOOM!!!
This silicon atom is made of a nucleus surrounded
by a cloud of electrons.
The nucleus is positively charged and the
cloud negatively charged, so they’ll respond
in opposite directions.
Now say some light comes in with an electric
field or polarization like this.
The nucleus will move with this and the cloud
of electrons will move against it.
Since the nucleus is 1000s of times more massive
than the cloud, the cloud’s motion dominates.
But that motion is accelerated and accelerating
charges emit light.
The motion of that electron cloud will generate
its own light and transmit that light out
the back side of the glass.
The outgoing light is polarized along the
direction the cloud was vibrating,
which is the same direction as the incoming light.
Polarizers work a little differently.
SUPER ZOOM!
The molecules in a polarizer form long chains.
Those chains are tightly bound which limits
motion along the chain.
If we send in the same light as before, something
different happens.
The cloud of electrons vibrates significantly
more perpendicular to the chain,
even if that doesn’t match the polarization of the light.
We call that perpendicular direction the polarizer’s
axis.
The motion of that electron cloud will still
generate its own light and still transmit
that light out the back side of the material.
That outgoing light must still be polarized
along the direction of the wiggle,
but now that's a new direction.
There’s just one weird problem left to address.
The light that comes from a lightbulb or
the Sun is said to be unpolarized.
UNPOLARIZED!?!?!
How can an EM wave NOT have an electric part?
How is that even possible!?!
Because “light” and a “light beam”
are not the same thing.
This is not a beam of light.
A beam is actually a large collection of EM
waves, so it can have different properties
than a single EM wave.
Polarization is just an example of one of
those properties.
While one EM wave must have an electric direction
and, therefore, must have a polarization
the beam is made of many of these waves.
If their electric pieces kind of line up,
then we say the beam is polarized.
But if they’re all oriented randomly, the
directions cancel and we can say the beam
is unpolarized.
The beam is what you get when you add all
those waves together.
It’s just easier to focus on individual
waves now and then try make predictions about
the beam later.
So let’s do that.
Consider this polarizer with this axis.
Suddenly a light wave comes in with an electric
part in this direction.
The polarizer will still pass this portion
of that electric arrow.
That portion is smaller than the original,
so that wave comes out a little dimmer.
If the beam passing through the polarizer
is unpolarized, like sunlight, then the same
amount is going to get blocked no matter how
the polarizer is turned.
That’s because you’ve got some waves like
this
and some waves like this
and some waves like this.
We say, on average, about 50% of the light
gets through, but, in practice, it’s more
like 38% because no polarizer is perfect.
Polarized sunglasses have another added benefit.
Glare Reduction!
You know, that obnoxious bright light from
things like cars.
Anyway, there’s a reason it happens.
Light comes in from the Sun and reflects.
Most of it scatters giving us color, but,
at angles around Brewster’s angle, the reflected
light is polarized parallel to the surface.
This light can create some very bright reflections
and it’s almost completely blocked by our polarized sunglasses.
That’s because the axis of your glasses
is perpendicular to the polarization of light.
You can see the same thing when two polarizers
are perpendicular.
The light from a lot of LCD screens is also
polarized at 45 degrees,
so only half the light gets through your sunglasses.
If you turn the sunglasses, you
can make the screen appear darker or lighter.
So to summarize:
Polarized sunglasses use long chains of molecules
that can only vibrate in one direction,
to block a little over half of normal light
and almost all glare.
Plus, they’re super stylish.
What’s the weirdest thing you’ve noticed
looking through polarized sunglasses?
Please share in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you want to
keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s ok to
be a little crazy.
Also, to everyone who is wondering:
WHAT ABOUT PHOTONS?!
Don’t freak out!
It’s coming!
It’s just that, without this video, the
video on photons would have come off a little abstract.
I had to make this one first.
Anyway, thanks for watching!